[Music]
[Applause]
let me guess you look at Stewie's
infamous behold and you see a feisty
little freedom fighter a scrappy
up-and-comer who against every odd
became one of five misfits to cement
themselves as the unlikely a saviors
North American Counter Strike has ever
seen they say what he understood they
weren't heavy on this up but they fit it
for those America yeah I bet you're
getting all misty-eyed watching that
aren't you yeah that's cute you know
what I see a disrespectful little [ __ ]
see before he even won a major and a
grand slam
before he become the first na Counter
Strike player to amass a million dollars
in prize winnings Jake Stewie 2k yet was
pretty much the most hated prodigy in
csgo history from his high for
aggressive peaks to his nutty ass pop
flashes
Stu became notorious for adopting a
cocky in-your-face play style that was
as innovative as it wasn't reverenced
rdptour jump in there but Stewie earned
his now infamous moniker for the way he
played around one piece of utility in
particular he's gonna come to this city
and that's what turn to
balls-to-the-wall BM inducing pug star
into a pioneer a revolutionary an outlaw
known only as the smoker criminal ok so
how did the venerable young Stuart mm to
become the smoke whisperer
well it all started about five years ago
when he first started to take CS goes
amateur scene by storm
you started playing counter-strike in
October 2014
yes yeah okay wait hold on did I hear
that right
during 2014 a buddy of mine decided I
should play csgo and get to be a thirsty
Stewie started playing counter-strike in
2014 and like three and a half years
later won a major yeah I'm done nope
now to be fair Stewie had played a
little bit of 1.6 when he was younger
but not seriously instead he spent his
time honing his mechanics in fast paced
arena esque titles such as Call of Duty
and League of Legends you know norming
[ __ ]
but those roots actually proved to be
invaluable unlike his opponents who
pretty much been indoctrinated with the
methodical traditions of Counter Strike
Stewie played fast
he pushed absolutely everything he gave
zero shits played with zero fear and
showed zero respect
but there was one deceptively simple
thing that turned young Stu
into the bane of NES elite one smart yet
seemingly smooth brained maneuver that
made him a total headache he always
pushed smokes and in an instant it's all
ruined Lucas to be walking past the
smoke seats on the other side
is he gonna check it it's gonna fade any
second now he's actually walking in
behind and should be an easy kill but he
wants more he's gonna pick up the one
goes into the middle and Stuart you see
since time immemorial there's been this
sort of unwritten rule in Counter Strike
that once an entryways been smoked off
it's just off-limits until the smoke
subsides now to be fair there's plenty
of good reason for this you can't see
your opponents they can't see you and if
you push the smoke someone is probably
holding the angle so in the majority of
cases it's safer to just back off and
well wait the problem is that once
you've been playing like this for over a
decade and a half it becomes the norm
something that your opponent's never
expect you to deviate from since it
would be felt
idiotic
oh my god see that was the genius of
scuse apparent stupidity nobody expects
you to do something not silver one that
consistently
yes and man did it piss people off
you just ran the site you ran through
smoke stewey
idiots kind of [ __ ] history so much
dude
Stu quickly cemented himself as
something of a menace a spectral smoke
pushing psychopath whose sole purpose
was to terrorize the finest fraggers
north america had to offer the kid was
basically the [ __ ] lizard king of
counter-strike everywhere you turned
there he was Wow I'm The Lizard King
naturally it didn't take long for people
to start realizing that Stewie was the
real deal within a year of becoming an
amateur he was chosen to be Cloud nines
contentious new fists at which point he
began to endear himself to the very
figures he'd been pissing off in terms
of up-and-coming young player young
talent
Stuart's UK is literally nuts and I
believe he's gonna be top of na I really
do but there were those who doubted him
because at heart he was also he knows
how to do is get close and I I tell him
that all done he gets mad he takes it
personal and I tell him he's a shitty
trollers he doesn't know how to [ __ ]
in mid-game he doesn't know anything
about wicked if people aren't in front
of Stewie's [ __ ] Serena's jail then
he's useless literally useless
there was even that one weirdo who
accused him of cheating
remember that [ __ ] in the suit who
kept getting meme Don for saying crisp
clean loft boys here we go he locks on
and again afterwards he starts doing
this weird shake it's the same pattern
he locks on the enemy then starts doing
his weird [ __ ] shape this one's right
on crisp
clean lock boys doesn't get more
horseshit than that the best part is
that he only ever referred to wall
and/or aim hax as the gear on the
[ __ ] gear boys these pros already
good but they're using the gear to get
an advantage these probes without the
[ __ ] gear they're good anyways but to
get an advantage over each other they're
using the [ __ ] I mean how could you
take this guy seriously he sounds like
Ricky from the Trailer Park Boys mr.
stupid ehed [ __ ] pissing me off right
now
thinks he's a captain of the [ __ ] liner
and by the way your fish sticks sucks
needless to say Stewie did end up
excelling at the professional level and
much of it had to do with his ability to
inject the big leagues with a healthy
dose of BM fire on the bomb so jks swaps
with a smoke down miss Joey he's gone
for the night he's gonna go for and he
does it Stewie he might find this clutch
and he goes again for more it's trading
back and forth but Stewie he finds the
clutch he finds a round on cloud nine
with a second pistol or he's fired up
with tranship towards banana yes sir
well he doesn't have to help anymore in
liquid just sneak by in that round
I can't believe called inclues Corner
not gonna lie to you yeah that is see
Stewie was among the first wave of csgo
pug stars to make it all the way into
the top tier and while he definitely had
to become a little bit less of a [ __ ] to
outperform world class competitors he
never lost sight of what made him so
explosive to begin with
so [ __ ] and neither did anyone else
likes to was jumping across the stairs
before the smoke pop and then what does
he do he catches s key members with
grenades in their hands because they're
about to smoke or Molly palace and then
steals like a [ __ ] or whatever the
smoke criminal strikes again and even
though he has matured and isn't quite
the same smoke of using dick he once was
every now and then you'll see the
venerable esteemed student mm revert
back to his old ship disturbing self why
because bro it wins games Chris J trying
to read something territory yet he knows
is defense you never play out history to
K means strong now it was too short
Kerrigan removed and he find the second
flashbang goes over is it enough it
looks like it that is phenomenal
Stewie 2k not slowing down at this point
flashbang goes in he wants to keep
applying the press here Molotov towards
sport look how this to you he's trying
to take that out surely everyone he does
take down his daddy fight boxing yes
because even though he's not around as
often as he used to be the spirit of
young stood on nor forgotten it lives on
in the hearts of huggers everywhere
yeah Meyer Stewie Stewie Stewie Stewie
and legend has it if you play passive
enough you're guaranteed to stumble upon
the smoke criminal who sits ready and
waiting to strike again yeah like so you
said yeah I'm done no no this is
[ __ ] nope nope I'm done nope
no [ __ ] you no [ __ ] you this is [ __ ]
nope [ __ ] this this is